we are still nearly a month away from
the official start of summer but there's
already been a string of recent shark
attacks across the country from Florida
and New Jersey to Hawaii but experts say
they are rare and should not stop people
from enjoying the ocean meanwhile a team
of scientists is working to increase the
shark population by trying to protect
the water where they mate Carter Evans
joined them for an up-close look at
their research
we met researchers 12 miles off the
Carolina coast on a ship that's
essentially a science lab at Sea
tracking great white sharks we're in
this Golden Era of returning the ocean
to abundance Chris Fisher founded
osearch to study the rebound of Atlantic
Fisheries since Marine protections were
enacted in the 1990s we're seeing an
ocean that's teeming with life like we
haven't seen since the 40s or 50s and he
says the increase in the number of
Atlantic great white sharks
CBS News was there when they tagged
their very first one in 2012.
they've now captured tested and released
more than 90 great white sharks and
track their migration patterns for years
we know almost everything except for
proving where they mate so this location
is that key area yes we believe that
mating is likely going on somewhere in
this region about now and that's why
we're here with the bait in the water
the Sharks emerge where is it right over
here they appear to be curious but also
cautious at this point we are literally
surrounded by sharks they are circling
the boat that's the big one that's what
scientists want to catch
finally one takes the bait
fish best guess is female 15 foot that's
exactly what we're looking for
like a dog on a leash the team leads the
shark onto a submerged platform
the research team Springs into action
they're working like a NASCAR pit crew
out here fast trying to get these
satellite tags installed because they've
only got 15 minutes that they can keep
this animal out of the water they take
blood samples and even perform an
ultrasound all while the shark is awake
and unsedated I just want to get right
in here and get a look I mean oh my gosh
I mean I've never been this close to
such a massive animal before sea Waters
pump through her gills to keep her
breathing can I touch one of her teeth
yeah
oh my God within minutes samples are
collected for 24 different scientific
studies including one testing hormone
levels to see if she's mating 13-3 she's
a 13 foot
female great white shark Chief scientist
Dr Bob shooter says finding the shark's
breeding ground will lead to a better
understanding of how we can protect them
as we bring them back then we set the
the ocean back you know into balance and
and reset the system so that we have the
best health for not only for the for the
Sharks but for ourselves and now that
there are more of these Predators
swimming among us we actually need to
retrain ourselves on how to play and
enjoy and recreate and embrace a more
wild abundant ocean look at the ocean
before you walk into it you don't want
to walk into a bait ball with birds
diving on it and Game fish on it because
sharks are going to be on it I mean
certainly if you saw a mountain lion
putting a stalk on a herd of elk you
wouldn't walk out into the middle of the
elk herd so we need to approach the
water the same way we approach the land
Common Sense goes a long way for CBS
mornings I'm Carter Evans off the Outer
Banks of North Carolina